okay
yes
welcome chris good morning
well good morning everybody it's uh now
uh 9
15 and this is the meeting of the
licensing act 2003 committee
um i'll go straight into
the agenda um trish could are there any
apologies for absence i have been told
about a few
yes chairman there's apologies from
councillors bradford and
hawking
we are a few missing but i suspect
technology is the the reason
but yeah thanks for watching other other
apologies that other councils have been
informed about
no okay if i go on to item two
of the agenda um has everybody read the
minutes and are there any
questions or issues with the minutes
is the committee happy that i signed the
minutes as a
true record of the last meeting
david followed by council russell
do you want to oh do i have to unmute
you no
sorry chairman i was signing kevin i was
signifying that i agree that they're
fine to go oh sorry good point yes i
i agree thank you very much so proposed
and seconded by
councillor rollinson and secondly by
council russell that the minutes are a
true record
thank you very much um item three is
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest
i can't imagine there are but i need to
ask
i take it there are no decorations of
interest but that's fine
uh i now go on to item four which is a
review of this statement of licensing
policy
and andrea has proven prepared a
document i
trust everyone's read it um is andrea
around a tool to take us through it
no okay um let me get it up a second
we are required to update it and um
there has been an update and it's
done helpfully you read just from the
from the previous policy
um has everybody is everybody
has anybody got any questions about the
updated policy
i think council rollinson did
yes yes chairman if you're calling me
yeah
i'm calling you sorry yes i've lost you
shall they run through all the questions
that i have and
are they coming i think ron i think ron
from run through all of them yeah and a
lot of people to
agree with disagree or whatever yeah
sure yeah i'm sure
so on paragraph four
point three point one
the last red section which is
and inspections will only be carried out
when and if they are necessary
that's fine by me i just wonder if we
can also
keep the little bit that's crossed out
which is premises with high risk rating
will be
in will be in need of more frequent
uh reviews so i didn't see why we should
need to take that out
it might give us more um flexibility
in targeting problem areas
uh would you like to propose i guess
that's a proposal from councilwoman
yeah yep thank you very much is there
any um is there a second one is there
any
thoughts on that from the committee yeah
sorry to interrupt
um i can't message andrew is having
technical difficulties and trish has
suggested that we stop from them
see if she can get in just so she can
answer obviously your question
that would be brilliant tell you what
would be helpful then is uh we won't
take a vote on that just yet
um whether council robinson could go
through his other
points uh while we wait for andrea and
then we can
so we're advised of what what questions
are going to be asked
david do you want to carry on yeah okay
okay chairman
that one then um
4.5.3
which is a minor thing it's regarding
the last sentence
about psos i just think there's a typing
error there it should be
no we have no yeah so pspos
not
sorry excuse me four 4.5
0.10 i can find that in mine
this is about the immigration act
and there's a requirement that the local
authority has to be satisfied that an
applicant has the right
to work in the uk that's fine
it's just how we go about satisfying
ourselves because
that could lead to some delicate
questions and people
yes some
other motives for asking the question so
i wondered whether
guidelines on every applicant is asked
those questions regardless or
i mean if we want a reason to ask it we
need to be careful what we're basing
those reasons on
so i mean that's one for officers to
advise possibly
yes i think i think that's a question
for andrew and that's more opera
operational
side than necessarily to be in yeah
it's worth mentioning yes it's a
sensitive area yeah
that that's right and i'm sure i know we
have the appropriate policies in place
and i know our officers train us on that
regularly so i'm not
unduly worried it's just something to
flag up on that one
and five
no sorry i'm still on four yeah sorry
four point five point eleven
um in the equality act
i i just wondered why we couldn't add
the the things to look at would be
um access disability access as a
condition
that we look at i couldn't see that it
was explicit in that
i know it's probably related
to licenses yeah i thought well why
can't they because it would sound to me
to be good practice if we could do it
that that would be the end of my
questions chairman thank you very much
indeed
uh we'll just wait for andrea um
[Music]
sorry if any other council's got any
other comments about that
uh about document i think it's a good
document um uh
though i do take council ronson's points
need to be answered or dealt with
chairman i wanted to prefix my
questions on that i thought it was a
very good document and
yeah and well laid out so
congratulations to the team that did
that
absolutely yes yeah so actually do you
want to make that a proposal and i'll
certainly second
is that we uh thank the the people who
produced this document
in quite difficult circumstances with
the coveted emergency
um so um i'll take a quick vote on that
yeah i'll second could we vote to say
thank you to the
is everybody happy with that yes yeah
thank you very much indeed that could be
recorded and we could tell the people
uh trisha that would be really helpful
no picture
chair if i could just i have not got an
update as such i think andrews
it's obviously um technical issues yeah
and we're still trying to get andrea in
and trish is also she's had to leave the
meeting going to try and rejoin because
she had to the youtube and the other
meeting going on in her headset
so she so she should be back with her i
think she's coming back in now
right um
marie have you i appreciate that it's
andrea's show but have you any comments
on
um council rollinson's questions about
about it from a legal point of view i
don't suppose it really makes much
difference really
sorry to put you on the spot
no um nothing um specific
um i don't think there's anything that
cause any legal
concern obviously we're referring to
equality's act immigration act but
yeah everything will be done in line
with the legislation
so um yeah nothing's
causing any concern at the moment
could i ask you could i ask a question
to the chairman also the officer do they
does this document go to the mp at all
for comment
whether it be in a gut with a government
legislation it's just a
interesting problem i'm not sure would
you like it to
because it does follow government
legislation and
um i don't know whether we have any
contact with our mp
about things that we are trying to do on
the government's behalf
as to whether it's correct
or they are if they if there is a view
it's
you know it's something maybe can be
answered later but it
i don't know whether we've ever done
that it would be interesting to know
we ought to keep them informed and send
them a copy yeah
i don't know the specific answer to that
chair
um again it's something andrew may know
the answer but i know
that the list of consultees is huge it
goes out to
every license prep i would imagine that
it does go to the mp or she could
certainly
have sight of it should she need to
because the list of consultees is huge
that's fine that's fine so and obviously
it goes um follows the process once
you've looked at it today it's still got
to be approved for
it goes out to consultation after today
and eventually will it be approved
um by full council later in the year
there is a time i have read the
timetable set out somewhere
and i'm not sure where that timetable is
again andrea will be able to assist
um if we don't get speech or i will see
if i can find the timetable at some
point for you all
and also for councillor kurzweil that
mel stride is also an mp that covers
team bridge
yes of course ladies
it's just a thought you know no no so
it's a good point it's a good point no i
agree
the timetable yes report
at the end it is yes yeah
i think there's a console t list as well
somewhere on there as well he's
where he says huge
sorry chris let me to try and unmute you
yeah yeah oh you're gonna make myself
well done let me know
i just think that let you know i'm not a
member of this committee that's the
reason i'm not voting
i'm just an ordinary counsellor
listening and i happen to be
a substitute on licensing so i thought
it was essential that
i took up the cuddles to listen to what
was going on that was all
it's at the next meeting it's at the
next meeting where i
agreed uh well i've been basically i
mustn't speak so the next meeting so
that that clears up anybody's
understanding why i'm sitting
here and not voting yes have you all
right
thank you chris i'm not a member
oh brilliant andrea um
did you want to say anything about your
document
oh
working quite well last week but um yeah
the um
draft policy that you have before you um
it's it's something that has to be done
every five years
i think this is not full policy now the
document has been amended in red
um which you can see it includes changes
to legislation uh changes to the
sections that are set out in relation to
the section 182 guidance
that local authorities also adopted um
rewording with some of the paragraphs
just to make it a little bit more
clearer
moving um paragraphs to allow a better
flow
of the policy and also there's been a
section added in relation to
safeguarding
which has been approved by the south
sudan and dartmoor community safety
partnership manager
so that's a bit like just a breakdown of
the details of what the changes have
happened within the policy
so mission
to sort the commencement of the
consultation which we're hoping to start
on friday
for 12 weeks when it will then be open
up to everyone to make representations
and then we'll be brought back to you
um to agree disagree any of the
amendments before it then goes to full
council
for final approval
thank you very much indeed i'm afraid
you missed it but we did we did vote to
say thank you for your
your hard work in producing that uh
document we're very we're very impressed
with it
um council rollinson had some had some
questions about it i think one was a
grammatical um
matter um but if i hand over to
councillor rollins and
if you could go through yet again
council robinson
uh your points about it just just slot
only slight
slight bits and pieces thank you council
rollinson
hey thank you chairman um and
thank you very much for um andrea it's a
good document
indeed um and i particularly like the uh
the safeguarding additions i thought
that was very thorough and a big
improvement
my questions um
are relating to um
paragraphs four in the main if i can
find them
again right 4.3.1
um the last lines in red
in that section was inspections will
only be carried out
when and if they are necessary i was
proposing that we could
also keep in the crossed out line
as well about the high risk
property properties being inspected more
frequently
that's fine i'm happy to do that if
that's all agreed that's fine i'm happy
to do that
okay excellent i think can we
well is anybody objecting to that
don't think they are in which case i
think should we just make that amendment
then is that okay
yeah yeah that's fine yeah brilliant
carry on david
um and then the other one the
grammatical
thing i feel a bit nitpicky on this but
five points sorry
4.5.3
where it's uh you say we currently have
not
pspos i think that maybe should be no
not we have no psos
just a matter of a t at the end of the
oh yeah
yeah that's fine no thank you you can
read the document
time and time again you still didn't
know don't notifications
it was
[Music]
[Laughter]
moving on kevin 4.5.10
immigration act i was just
wondering about asking questions
as to whether we're satisfied that
an application is entitled to work in
the uk
is how we would go about that i think i
can understand the need to do it
um i just thought is that something
every applicant will be asked
to ensure that we are fair to everybody
or
uh i thought any other way might might
be screwed
um viewed as an insensitive maybe
each individual application form
requires them to
provide documentation if they're
applying as individuals
so that's um on new app new premises
license applications
personal licenses um and transfers of
premises licenses
so they've all got their own section
within the application
form of when they have to supply this
information so it's a universal
thing on the form that that sounds very
appropriate
is good yeah um and then
4.5.11 at the end
uh you say that where um conditions
relating to disability disabled access
will not be attached to the license
i wonder why not it would seem to me
that being a good thing to do
um i think that's because that's dealt
with under other legislation
so if building building legs and things
like that when they go in to inspect
properties i think that's the
requirement that they have to do it's
not
it's not a condition that we can place
on the license itself
so it's a legal thing and you dealt with
elsewhere
yeah well thank you chairman that that
was the end of my questions on that and
again thank you very much andrew a great
document
thank you are there any other questions
for
andrea
that being so i'm going to propose from
the chair
that uh the document goes out for
consultation and obviously we'll come
back to the full council
and i'll propose that from the chair so
i don't need a seconder um
all those in favor can you wave as well
as do your blue hand
chairman sorry yes you do need a
secondary please
oh do i offer a chairman
thank you very much there you go thank
you very much
all those in favor again sorry of uh
this going out to consultation and then
obviously going to full council
i think that's unanimous but i can't be
sure
chairman can we ask if there's anyone
against
is there anyone against that's a good
idea
no voices and any abstentions please any
abstentions
no that's that's unanimous chairman
thank you thank you very much indeed
thank you
thank you trish thank you uh
andrea for with the technology issues
for all that
good piece of work we did vote to say
thank you to you and and everyone
involve your team involved in it
um unless i can't think of no other
reason why we should now not declare the
meeting closed
thank you thank you very much indeed
thanks thanks everybody and um
some of you all need to sorry i said
thank you
oh thank you chris did you have
something to say sorry chris
no no that's fine uh there's a
subcommittee after oh sir john yeah
yeah my sister apologies for being late
i must admit i thought it was ten
o'clock but
i looked again when beth sent me the
thing through so i apologize for that
no problem thank you very much indeed um
obviously i declare the meeting close
thank you for your attendance uh some of
you need to stay for a subcommittee
but uh those who don't i shall say would
you would you mind leaving now thank you
very much
indeed thank you council for your
attendance
chairman am i on the subcommittee
trish am i on the subcommittee no
no cancer curse or you're not no thank
you
but i am trish yes
yes councillor nettle and councillor
russell and councillor olson
and that's at 10 30. thank you
do we leave now tristan signing again to
10 o'clock
uh yes councillor rollerson thank you if
you could leave the meeting and um
sign in on the next one at half past 10
for the hearing
the meeting starts at half temperatures
do we sign in a little earlier
yeah yes if you could would you like if
you could join the
meeting please at um